the Triwizard Tournament is a magical
contest that is held between three of
the larger schools in the Wizarding
World Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry
beauxbatons academy of magic and the
durmstrang institute the location of the
tournament varies from year to year and
can be held at any of the three schools
as suggested by its name the contest
features three wizards or witches
referred to as champions each school is
represented by one champion who attempts
to complete three dangerous tasks that
have been designed to test that
champions courage intelligence
resourceful 'no sand magical ability of
course the year of 1994 was an exception
as we saw Harry take part in a contest
as not only an underage wizard but as
the fourth champion students who wish to
enter would only have to write their
names on a piece of parchment and place
that into the Goblet of Fire the Goblet
then selected the students that it
believed to be the best from each school
each student chosen will be bound by a
magical contract and had to see the
tournament through to the end the
champions received points based on their
performance these points were given up
by the Headmaster's and had mistresses
of the compete in schools who played the
role of judges the tournament was
renowned for being extremely dangerous
and over the years several champions
died while competing in the 1972
triwizard tournament all three of the
judges along with multiple students were
badly injured when a task involving a
cockatrice went wrong this led to the
tournament being discontinued after 1972
due to the high death toll the
tournament was finally revived in 1994
but this time there were restrictions
put in place to prevent the death of
those taken part all applicants now had
to be over the age of 17 to enter
but if this tournament was so dangerous
then why were there so many wizards and
witches so eager to compete there were
several rewards for those who won the
Triwizard Tournament the winner does of
course receive a prestigious Cup and as
nice as this Cup would look on a mantel
somewhere
the thought of it being a potential
portkey teleporting you to a bunch of
Death Eaters in Lord Voldemort makes
this award seem far less appealing the
winner also receives 1,000 gold galleons
but with one galleon equated to around
five muggle pounds or six or seven
dollars you won't exactly be able to
retire after winning the try was a
tournament if you're more into Fame then
as mentioned by Dumbledore himself
eternal glory
is what awaits the winner of the
Triwizard Tournament this brings us to
1994 and the most recent Triwizard
Tournament on September 1st Albus
Dumbledore announced that Hogwarts would
play host to the latest Triwizard
Tournament and on the 30th of October
the participating schools arrived at
Hogwarts the beauxbatons in a large
carriage carried by a braixen horses and
those from durmstrang in a magical ship
that could travel underwater once the
tournament and its rules had been
explained students had until the start
of the Halloween feast to enter their
names in the Goblet of Fire in order to
stop any underage wizards or witches
from entering the tournament there was
an age line drawn around the goblet of
fire the champions chosen to compete for
as follows Viktor Krum from the
durmstrang Institute Fleur Delacour
of the beauxbatons and Cedric Diggory
would be the Hogwarts champion after a
brief pause and to the surprise of
everyone the Goblet of Fire released a
fourth named Harry Potter just as Bertie
Crouch jr. planned despite the
displeasure of the other schools
Hogwarts would have two champions
representing them this year
before the tournament could commence
each champion would have to have their
ones tested to ensure that they won't
work in order the ones would be examined
by Garrick Ollivander and once satisfied
that all ones were in working order the
tournament could begin the first task
took place on the 24th of November and
each champion had to retrieve a golden
egg that was guarded by a dragon in
order to decide which dragons they'd
have to face the champions took an
intern to pull a random miniature
version of these dragons from a bag
Cedric Diggory was the first to begin
the task and would face the swedish
short snout with the use of a
Transfiguration spell he turned a
boulder into a dog in order to distract
the dragon for the most part Cedric was
successful but whilst retrieving the egg
his face was badly burnt by the dragon
despite his injuries he was still able
to complete the task Fleur Delacour was
second and made short work of the
commonwealth's green she faced by
enchanting the dragon to sleep Viktor
Krum retrieved his egg from the chinese
fireball by using a conjunctive as curse
to bind the dragon he was later deducted
points as a dragon stumbled destroying
half of the real eggs that the golden
egg was amongst last stop was harry
facing the hungarian horntail widely
regarded as the fiercest of the four
dragons using the advice given to him by
Bertie Crouch jr. who was disguised as
Professor Moody Harry summoned his broom
and outmaneuvered the dragon he did have
his shoulder slashed by the dragon
meaning he was deducted points but he
was also successful by the end of the
first task Victor and Harry were tied in
first place Cedric in second and Fleur
in third the champions were not told
what the second toss was only that the
golden egg they had retrieved contained
a clue on how to pass the second task
without deciphering the clue it would be
almost impossible to complete the second
task
after opening the egg underwater a verse
was recited and with a little help from
Moaning Myrtle
Harry worked out that the second task
involved swimming in the Black Lake the
only issue was that Harry had to figure
out a way that he could breathe
underwater for an hour Crouch jr. made
sure that never was in possession of a
book that had the answer to Harry's
dilemma and in the movie Neville does
help Harry with the use of gillyweed
however in the books that wasn't the
case Crouch jr. still disguised as
Professor moody summoned the house of
Dobby who overheard a discussion between
himself and Professor McGonagall
regarding gillyweed and the second task
wanted to help his friend Harry
they'll be stole some gillyweed from
Professor Snape's private potions store
on the morning of the task
Harry was awoken by Dobby who gave him
the gillyweed all four champions were
told that they had one hour to retrieve
something that had been stolen from them
the gillyweed gave Harry gills allowing
him to breathe underwater as well as
webbed hands and feet Cedric and Fleur
both used the bubblehead charm and
Victor transfigured himself into a shark
as the four made their way through the
village of the merpeople they discovered
that it was not an item that was taken
but a person they held dear Fleur was
forced to retire after she was attacked
by the green delouse Harry was the first
to reach the village but he was more
concerned with the safety of all the
other hostages as well as wrong Cedric
and Victor arrived shortly after
carrying away both their respective
hostages with no sign of Fleur Harry
chose to rescue both of the remaining
hostages the merpeople were tempted to
stop Harry but after a short tussle
Harry was able to break free and dragged
Ron and Fleur sister to the surface
Harry finished in third place but after
a short discussion between the judges he
was awarded second place for sure an
outstanding moral fiber Harry and Cedric
were now tied in first place with Victor
in second and flourish still in third
[Music]
the third and final task took place on
the 24th of June the task involved
navigating through a maze and reaching
the Cup located in the centre having
finished in first place Harry and Cedric
were allowed to enter the maze first
followed by victor and then Fleur the
maze contain dangerous obstacles that
each champion would have to overcome
Harry encountered a boggart in the form
of a Dementor and had to deal with a
golden mist that turned things upside
down Crouch jr. made sure that Harry had
a clear path to victory stunning an
immobilizing Fleur and using the
Imperius curse on Victor to make him
attack Cedric Harry and Cedric would
eventually join forces to make it
through the maze and after a brief
argument over who deserved to win they
both touched a cup together the cup was
a portkey and upon touching it both of
them were transported a little hang
wilton where Lord Voldemort and his
Death Eaters awaited the arrival of
Harry they witnessed Peter Pettigrew
carrying a weakened Lord Voldemort and
on his orders Pettigrew then killed
Cedric with the killing curse after
being part of the ritual that returned
Lord Voldemort to his previous strengths
Harry an ER doc Lord then had a short
duel Harry would eventually make it back
to the cup with Cedric's body takin them
back to Hogwarts
this trial is a tournament was used by
Voldemort to return his body to its most
powerful state and the results were most
definitely manipulated by him and his
followers after the death of Cedric
Diggory and Voldemort's return being
made public the 1994 trial was a
tournament was the last to ever be held
the Triwizard Tournament was held 125
times with Hogwarts winning 63 times and
beauxbatons that remain in 62 it does
seem a little bit strange that in 125
attempts durmstrang were never able to
win I'd love to hear from you guys do
you like the idea of the Triwizard
Tournament or like me do you find that
it's had out of place within a school I
can see the tournament making sense some
working in the Wizarding World with
adult wizards and witches but it does
seem unnecessarily dangerous for young
students if you'd like to see more of
the exploring Harry Potter series then
please let me know suggestions for
future videos are always welcome as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
you